♪ ♪
>> VOTERS GIVING THE SQUAD A
MAJOR SCARE OVER THEIR RADICAL
POLICIES.
ILHAN OMAR NARROWLY SURVIVING A
PRIMARY BATTLE AGAINST A
PRO-POLICE DEMOCRAT.
SQUEAKING OUT A WIN.
HER OPPONENT RAN IN PART BECAUSE
OF HOW FED UP HE WAS WITH
ILHAN OMAR'S EFFORTS TO DEFUND
THE POLICE.
GREG GUTFELD, SHE SQUEAKED BY.
ARE YOU HAPPY SHE STILL IN
CONGRESS OR ARE YOU --
>> LOOK, THE RACE WAS AS CLOSE
AS EL HAN AND HER BROTHER BUT
SHE STILL WANTED, WE JUST HAVE
TO HOPE THE REPUBLICANS COME UP
WITH SOMETHING THAT --
NEVER MIND.
LISTEN, IS A DEPRESSIVE STORY
FOR ME IN AMERICAN POLITICS.
BUT SAFETY WAS THE AMERICAN
SYSTEM.
SHE WAS IN A REFUGEE CAMP AND
SHE CAME TO AMERICA IN 1995 AND
BECAME A CITIZEN AND ALL SHE
DOES IS RAIL AGAINST THE
AMERICAN SYSTEM.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT'S HOW SHE
FELT WHEN SHE WAS IN A REFUGEE
CAMP.
THE MORE ALONG THE LINES BEFORE
SHE -- WHAT SHE GOT HERE TONIGHT
SHE WAS RADICALIZED.
WHERE WAS SHE RADICALIZED?
NORTH DAKOTA STATE UNIVERSITY I
THINK IS WHERE SHE WENT.
IT ALSO BOTHERS ME THAT
PROGRESSIVES HAVE AN EDGE.
WHY IS SHE ONE?
THE WORK TO REMAKE SOCIETY IS
NEVER DONE BECAUSE TO CREATE
SITUATIONS LIKE THE FUNDING AND
RIOTING WHICH CREATED MISERY AND
UNREST.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS YOU SAY SEE?
OUR WORK IS FAR FROM DONE.
AS THEY KEEP THEIR CONSTITUENTS
IN MISERY THEY CAN PROMISE TO BE
THE SOLUTION.
>> DO YOU THINK THE VOTERS
THEMSELVES ARE TO BLAME A LITTLE
BIT?
THEY VOTE FOR PEOPLE AND THOSE
PEOPLE D FROM THE POLICE AND THE
PRIME RATE SEARCHES?
FLAT-CHESTED LIKE THE SAME
PERSON.
>> I THINK IT'S HARD TO BEAT AN
INCUMBENT IN THE SKY THAT TRIED
TO AGAINST HER WAS THAT HAD BEEN
A SUPPORTER OF HERS AND SAID
THAT THE PHONE THE POLICE WENT
TO FAR FROM HIM SO HE WAS GOING
TO GIVE IT A SHOT.
BUT SHE RAISES SO MUCH MONEY.
THE THING IS SHE'S BECOME VERY
USEFUL.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS SHOWN THEY
CARE A LOT MORE ABOUT PEOPLE
LIKE ILHAN OMAR THAN THEY DO
ABIGAIL SPANBERGER FOR EXAMPLE.
THEY JUST ANNOUNCED THAT THE
DEMOCRATS ON THE HOUSE I'D
DECIDED THEY WILL NOT PICK UP
THE POLICE FELT THAT THE
MODERATE DEMOCRATS WANTED.
SHE WAS A SPONSOR OF THAT.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN GOING TO
BOTHER TO BRING IT UP.
WHEN THEY SAY WE DIDN'T SAVE HER
FOR DEFENDING THE POLICE REMIND
THEM OF THAT AND ABOUT ABIGAIL.
>> POOR ABIGAIL.
SO THE SQUAD, HE MUST BE SO SICK
OF THESE PEOPLE.
DOES OMAR NEVER SAY ANYTHING
GOOD ABOUT THIS COUNTRY?
DO YOU REMEMBER THE LAST THING
SHE SAID?
>> I'M SURE IT EXISTS.
PULL THE TAPES.
SHE HAS TALKED ABOUT HOW ONLY IN
THIS COUNTRY IT'S POSSIBLE THAT
YOU CAN COME HERE AS A REFUGEE
AND THEN SHE SAID THAT.
>> SHE SAID DESTROY IT FROM
WITHIN.
>> MIGHT POLITICS ARE NOT
ALIGNED WITH THE FAR LEFT SIDE
OF MY PARTY AND I DON'T KNOW
ANYONE WHO ACTUALLY WASN'T
EXCITED ABOUT THE FACT THAT SHE
MIGHT LOSE HER SPOT.
IT'S PREDICTED THAT BY 2024 SHE
WILL LOSE.
SO IT'S INCHING TOWARDS BEING
ABLE TO BEAT HER.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU SAW THE
DOCUMENTARY, THE NETFLIX
DOCUMENTARY ABOUT THE
PROGRESSIVES THAT HAD AOC AND
CORI BUSH AND THE WOMAN
CHALLENGING JOE MANCHIN.
EVERYONE IN IT LOST BUT AOC.
IT'S NOT A WINNING FORMULA
UNLESS YOU ARE IN THE BLUEST OF
AREAS TO BE RUNNING AROUND
SAYING THE STUFF THAT THE SQUAD
IS SAYING.
IT DOESN'T WIN ELECTIONS.
ABIGAIL SPANBERGER AND MAKING
SURE ALL OF THOSE ONES ARE THE
ONES WINNING TOUGH ELECTIONS.
WE SHOULD BE SUPPORTING THOSE
KINDS OF POLICIES.
>> ALREADY, JUDGE, I KNOW YOU
LOVE OMAR.
YOU AND OMAR GO WAY BACK.
>> YES INDEED.
ILHAN AND I HAVE A HISTORY.
I HAVE FOUND THERE IS VERY
LITTLE SHE HAS SAID THAT IT IS
PRO-AMERICAN BUT I WILL LEAVE IT
OUTSIDE.
NO I'M NOT DONE, I WILL LEAVE
THAT POINT AT THAT.
ALREADY, SHE RAN AGAINST A GUY
THAT WAS PRO-LAW ENFORCEMENT,
SHE IS DEFUND THE POLICE, SHE'S
RUNNING IN A DEMOCRATIC DISTRICT
AGAINST SOMEBODY WHO WAS
REPUBLICAN AND IS HEAVILY
DEMOCRATIC DAY LOOKS LIKE
OBVIOUSLY SHE IS GOING TO WIN.
I THINK AS WE GO FORWARD MORE
AND MORE AS EVERYONE HAS BEEN
SAYING THE PROGRESSIVES ARE
LOSING AND MAYBE SHE MIGHT NOT
WIN.
AND THOUGH HER HISTORY PRETTY
WELL AND I'VE NEVER HEARD HER
SAY ANYTHING PRO-AMERICAN OR
ANYTHING POSITIVE ABOUT THE
COUNTRY THAT SAVE HER, GAVE HER
THE ABILITY TO LEAVE A WAR-TORN
AREA AND GET AN EDUCATION AND BE
A SUCCESS.
>> YOU HEARD OUR PREDICTION, SHE
WILL BE THE FIRST SQUAD M